we work very much just like kids being
kids on a set
my resident memory from the first
from philosopher's stones i just learned
how to play slam you know what we did a
lot of as well was that oh
yeah with like all of us like red like
red i think all sorts of knowledge
yeah i remember the shin version
yeah yeah
[Music]
they probably made their jobs harder for
themselves by letting us have as much
fun as we had because it distracted us
from
you know the work we were supposed to be
doing and for the other viewers get my
mouse trapped
like a big problem was like throughout a
take
our attention would like
would wane and come and go they say a
line and then they'd smile at the camera
or they were just so happy to be in a
harry potter film that they couldn't
contain their excitement long enough to
focus on an entire scene
mysterious thing time
when in doubt i find retracing my steps
to be a wise place to begin
[Music]
we've all got both light
and dark
inside
what matters
is the part we choose to act on
that's who we really are
[Music]
you